emergency preparedness bill blair
minister of public safety marco
mendicino and the minister of justice
and attorney general of canada david
lametty so prime minister trudeau will
make a few remarks and then we will turn
to questions a reminder it is 20 minutes
of questions 10 in the room and 10 on
zoom
in
hello everyone thank you very much
i'm accompanied today by prime minister
have been incredibly difficult for the
people of our capital city and they've
been stressful and disturbing for all
canadians
the situation is not anything anyone
wanted and quite frankly not anything
we'd want to see again
on monday after having consulted the
provinces and territories the federal
government invoked the emergency
measures act
the families and workers in ottawa are
gaining back their neighborhoods and
their freedoms i want to take a moment
to thank the law enforcement agencies
from across the country who joined the
operations
and i want to continue to thank them as
they ensure that among other things
canada's border crossings remain open
including in windsor
and that all communities are safe
we didn't want to use the emergencies
act it's never something to turn to
without serious consideration but after
weeks of dangerous and unlawful
activities after weeks of people being
harassed in their neighborhoods and
small businesses forced to close
after billions of dollars were stalled
in trade putting people's jobs and
livelihoods at risk
after the national war memorial was
desecrated
after evidence of increased
ideologically motivated violent
extremism activity across the country
after a flood of misinformation and
disinformation washed over canada
including from foreign sources
after these illegal blockades and
occupations received disturbing amounts
of foreign funding to destabilize
canada's democracy
it became clear
that local and provincial authorities
needed more tools to restore order
and keep people safe
for the past few days parliamentarians
have been debating the emergencies act
and will be voting on it tonight
i ask all members of parliament to take
action against illegal blockades and to
stand up for public safety
and for the freedom of canadians
invoking the emergencies act has been
necessary
law enforcement agencies relied on it to
set up secured areas in downtown ottawa
and at border crossings it prevented
foreign money from continuing to fund
illegal blockades
and it's making sure our borders remain
open
it has been
the responsible thing to do
we now have a choice
to make as a society
we can choose to keep reliving these
scenes that tear at the values that bind
us as canadians
or we can choose to remember who we are
and the best vision
of what canada can be
what we've seen in these past weeks is
not the story of this pandemic the story
of this pandemic is one of unity
and solidarity
the pandemic
who come to work every day regardless of
how tired they are or the difficulties
that await them it's the story of
truckers and front line workers
who keep the economy running
it's the story
together to save lives
we've got some of the highest
vaccination rates in the world
made sacrifices
and yes it was difficult
the lives of 36 000 canadians
through this pain and heartbreak
canadians answered the call
because canadians
are good people
we're among the world leaders in
vaccination and health outcomes as well
as in economic recovery and job creation
it took courage
it took resilience
but we did it
together
and despite the many challenges that we
faced
our democratic institutions
remain strong
we don't always agree
and that's okay in fact it's not only
healthy to have debates in the democracy
it's necessary
our government will always
defend freedom of expression and freedom
of peaceful assembly these values
are at the core
of our charter of rights and freedoms
they're at the core of who we are as
canadians
in a democracy
you can protest you can share your
opinion at the top of your lungs
you can disagree with elected officials
you can certainly disagree with me
but you can't
harass your fellow citizens who disagree
with you
you can't hold a city hostage
you can't block a critical trade
corridor and deprive people of their
jobs
you can't attack journalists for
reporting
which is essential to our democracy
what you can do
is vote
what you can do is run for office
that's
how change happens in a democracy
but that doesn't mean you have the right
to participate in illegal blockades or
occupations or to put others in danger
and it's unacceptable
to attack a journalist because they're
doing their work or to intimidate people
and get in the way of the freedom of the
press
there's no doubt in the last weeks
have been trying times
but the last years
have been painful
but we can't let anger divide us
more than ever
now is the time to work together
it's also the time to reflect
on the kind of future we want for our
country
there's a lesson for all of us
in what happened this month
we don't know when this pandemic is
going to finally end
but that doesn't mean we can't start
healing as a nation
and it starts
with all of us
if you spend a lot of time online
try looking outside your social media
bubble every now and then
if you have a cousin
who you haven't seen in a while because
they're unvaccinated
or because they're vaccinated
give them a call
if a political conversation got heated
during a recent gathering and a friend
or relative left early
pick up the phone
not to try to convince them not to argue
but simply to ask
how they're doing
look
in the heat of the moment
we can all get carried away
trying to win an argument
but not every single conversation has to
be about winning an argument
sometimes
it's more important to just be there for
one another
as a country
let's aim for more decency in our public
discourse
not less
let's cherish the democracy that we have
and let's commit ourselves every day to
working together to make it even better
so like i said thank you very much 20
minutes of questions starting with
questions in the room so we have 10
minutes i would ask you ministers and
the prime minister if you could keep
your answers short that would be greatly
appreciated because we have a lot of
questions in the room and on zoom and
for people on zoom if you could use the
raised hand function to indicate that
you have a question that would be
greatly
david thurton cbc we'll start with david
thornton cbc
do we still need the emergencies act the
blockades have been cleared parliament
hill is being cleared
do we still need it
as i said the emergencies act is not
something to undertake lightly
and it's something that needs to be
momentary
temporary
and proportional
that's why every single day i'm
receiving briefings and we are
reflecting on how much longer the
emergencies act needs to be in place we
don't want to keep it in place a single
day longer than necessary
but even though
the blockades are lifted across border
openings right now
even though
things seem to be resolving very well in
ottawa this state of emergency is not
over
there continues to be real concerns
about the coming days
but we will continue to evaluate every
single day
whether or not it is
time and we are able to lift this state
of emergency
but i will turn to ministers mendicino
and blair who on this question i wanted
to say a couple of words
thank you very much prime minister and
thank you for the question
look i i think there's no doubt that we
have seen significant progress here in
ottawa and after
uh three weeks of um torment uh for
local residents for small businesses
um for um you folks who've been
reporting and
you know the
the images have been shocking and at
times and deeply concerning um this
morning and yesterday
we saw uh calm
peace
and quiet
um and i think that that was certainly a
sense of relief for all of us
but
we know that there are still a number of
individuals who are affiliated with the
illegal blockades were in the area just
this morning
we saw that there are some reports for a
potential
activity
in the area so we have to remain
vigilant and not only in ottawa but at
our ports of entry a couple of days ago
there was an effort to try and block
surrey an important trade corridor at
the pacific highway
we continue to watch very closely
activities in windsor and we're
following the advice of our law
enforcement and i would just point out
that
we've had a number of individuals
reached out reach out including
the canadian association chiefs of
police the ontario association chiefs of
police the canadian association of
police members who are the rank and file
who have said to us with a very clear
and singular voice that the emergencies
act is a tool
that is continuing to not only address
the illegal occupation here
in ottawa but also being used very
effectively to prevent future blockades
now i want to
echo exactly what the prime minister
said which is i think a sentiment that
we all share across government and that
is we do not want to use the emergencies
act for a single moment longer than is
necessary and i believe that when you
survey the conduct of
law enforcement over the last number of
days what you have seen is restraint
i mean take a look at the way that um
the police carried themselves throughout
the course of uh dealing with the
illegal occupation here in ottawa there
was a degree of professionalism and
focus despite the fact that there was an
emotionally charged atmosphere despite
the many provocations and intimidation
and at times uh efforts to
assault uh police officers and that
despite all of that we saw a minimum use
of force so i think that that uh that
kind of conduct will continue to carry
uh through the emergencies act but we
won't use it uh for any longer that is
necessary
i'll take your point david
um i think clearly the the police have
have used and and the measures that we
brought forward in the emergency act um
appropriately and to to significant
effects we're pleased with the progress
that's being made we're monitoring on a
daily and now even hourly basis the
threat environment with our senior
officials and with law enforcement and
we are committed
to to ending this emergency at the
earliest opportunity but clearly we're
not out of the emergency yet and and so
we'll continue to monitor that very
carefully um i hope that satisfactory
david
we bonjour has
what is the threshold to remove it
because the truckers could come back in
two months three months so does that
mean we have to keep it uh for another
two three months
this is something that we're thinking
about of course
at some point
once it's lifted
we'll have to remain vigilant
as to what could happen afterwards but
we still feel
that
now
right
keeping an eye on this each day and see
when we can
but every day we're going to reevaluate
and we hope that we won't keep it for
one day longer than necessary hi there
it's andy bergeron for ctv national news
my question is from mr freeland i
believe uh two conservative mps say that
their constituents who donated small
amounts about 50 or so have had their
bank accounts frozen i'm wondering if
this is a case of a mistaken use of
powers granted to banks under the
emergencies act or is the government
going after
any donor including small donors
uh i'll turn to minister freeland in in
a second but
the measures that we put in place are
designed and focused on ensuring uh that
people in the current illegal
occupations leave that has been the
intent and the focus right now if there
are specific cases that conservative
ministers can bring forward to highlight
uh where that is uh is not the case we
would happily look at them and hope to
resolve them but i'll turn over to
minister freeman
thank you
um yeah thanks for the question so first
of all just as the prime minister said
particularly
right now
at a time which is very fraught
it's important for all of us to be very
very careful
to get our facts exactly right in each
circumstance
and i would urge all of us
to take that care in every situation
in terms of the financial measures
uh the rcmp
has
given to the financial institutions
names of
leaders and organizers of the protests
and of people whose trucks
were part of occupations and blockades
that is the only information
according to the rcmp that the rcmp has
given to financial institutions
i think it's also really important
for everyone to be clear and this speaks
to
the getting our facts straight point
that
these measures applied
only as of
the 15th of february
that is when
financial support
of these illegal blockades and
occupations
began to be sanctioned
and then finally let me say
for
anyone
who
is concerned that their accounts may
have been frozen
because of their participation in these
illegal blockades and occupation
the way to get your account unfrozen
is to stop being part of the blockade
and occupation this is this
these measures were put in place
to disrupt
illegal activity in canada
and
you know we were very clear last monday
that
we would be following the money
that we would be using financial tools
to
disrupt illegal blockades and
occupations the focus absolutely
has been on leaders
and on the vehicles that were such an
important part of the illegal blockades
and occupations that has been the only
focus
of law enforcement
thank you
i have a hard time imagining that a
parliamentarian no
votes no
to these measures this evening
imagine that
it would be something other than showing
responsibility
in
the
competency of the government
but i have
total
confidence that the majority of
parliamentarians
this evening will vote to protect the
rule of law
and protect canadians their communities
and their freedoms i can't imagine
that anyone who votes
no
tonight
is doing anything other than indicating
that they don't trust
the government
to make
incredibly momentous and important
decisions
at a very difficult time
but like i said i am confident that the
majority of parliamentarians will stand
up to support our values to stand up
support our democracy and to stand up to
support their fellow canadians
david aiken global news thank you for
taking our questions and thank you for
the kind words about supporting our work
i'd suggest the best way to do that of
course is take an extended amount of
time for questions from journalists
um
i i heard what you said in reply to my
friend david thurton and i heard the
very same similar lines repeated by
minister medicina repeated by minister
blair we don't want this to go on for
one second longer i really want to press
you give us a specific power in the
emergencies act which is vital right now
that is not present in the provincial
emergency orders in the criminal code
and any other number of statutes that
are is-6 what specifically is in that
act that is so vital right now to
protect canadians we saw for a number of
uh days and weeks into the the blockades
uh that it was extremely difficult to
get tow trucks to come and tow big rigs
one of the specific measures is an
ability to compel tow truck drivers
to come and do their jobs
when the emergencies act was brought in
many tow truck companies said okay
we'll do it didn't need to be compelled
but there were some companies that
needed to be compelled under the
emergencies act
to remove trucks and we've seen right
now that there are trucks holding in
places like
arnprior and embryon and other places
that are have indicated an indication a
desire or an openness to returning to
blockades right now so that is a power
we may well need
the
power to pro designate critical
infrastructure like border crossings as
not just the actual border crossing
itself which of course is protected
under current legislation but the
approaches
to border crossings 15 kilometers up the
road uh from kutz for example or
or
the municipal approaches to the windsor
crossing that require uh police to be
able to designate that as areas where
people not just occupying but indicating
a desire to go and occupy that
intersection can be turned away
just in the past days there was a convoy
from fort mcmurray destined for ottawa
that was largely turned away at the
manitoba ottawa border
based on
the
laws and the powers in the emergencies
act now this is not something that we
want to imagine continuing indefinitely
in canada we hope to only keep it in
place for
a number more days we will revaluate
every single day but right now
when the situation is still
of people
pre-positioning people uh
being out there indicating that they are
ready
to blockade to continue their illegal
occupations to disrupt canadians lives
we feel that this measure
needs to remain in place while this
emergency situation is still in place
and i could give other occasions but
i'll turn to another question instead to
try and get as many as possible
uh sir lee berthiam canadian press good
to see you um you've said you you don't
want to keep these the emergencies act
any longer than necessary but you have
also said that you want to make some of
the new powers around fundraising
platforms reporting to fintrac permanent
i'm wondering what other powers you're
looking at making permanent whether
other changes after this crisis have
passed
one of the things that is important and
right about the use of the emergencies
act is there are already
many mechanisms around review and
oversight whether it's a parliamentary
committee whether it's an inquiry
afterwards whether it's a need for
openness and transparency whether it's
even
court cases that are coming forward to
to challenge it all those are part of
the checks and balances that make sure
that these
actions we took
are the right ones which we
know they are
at the same time
there needs to be a reflection about
misinformation and disinformation
and
how
canadians lives can be disrupted by
there needs to be a reflection on
foreign funding
of
of illegal actions uh in our country
designed to disrupt or destabilize our
democracy
there have to be reflections on our
ability to keep our borders uh open and
free-flowing and protect critical
infrastructure like
the seat of our democracy
these are things that will be debated
and reflect on in time we will work with
parliamentarians to move forward in a
way that is responsible
and uh properly measured uh to
react and proact in terms of what we see
potentially coming in the coming years
okay thank you for that we are going to
go on questions on zoom over kamal cevic
you had said that the way to unfreeze
your account is to no longer take part
in the blockade however there are no
more blockades so are we to understand
that the funds will be unfrozen
soon
and if the vote is negative tonight does
that mean that automatically those
counts will be unfrozen
and if i may ask another one mayor
watson said that we should sell
the impounded vehicles would the law
allow for that
okay
thank you for the question
i will start by saying that it is very
important
they donate
have exact accurate data
the standards
on seized accounts are not shared with
politicians and that is
names of the
[Music]
have no connection
with the occupation or the blockade
and
it's important to be
sure
that the count account is not being
frozen for any other reason
who will then communicate with the
financial
institutions
this was a measure that was taken
and the blockage and the occupation
a retroactive measure it was a very
targeted measure
measure
[Music]
we have no intention
to take people's money this was really
a way to occupy and a barrage of
illegal blockades in occupation
and i can repeat that in english if it's
useful but if not
no no no okay
thank you
and as for the truckers
what about selling them
concerts
[Music]
remain with the municipality and the
province thank you
we're going to go to john ebbetson
global mail
good morning prime minister um
concerning the situation in ukraine if
russia were to recognize the
independence of uh dusan and donets and
send troops into the region would that
be sufficient to trigger sanctions by
canada and if it were not sufficient why
would that not be the case first of all
we continue to see russia
positioning itself and trying to create
excuses
or reasons
to violate ukrainian territorial
integrity to violate the sovereignty of
ukraine
and we continue
to stand against
all such measures we will
fully stand for the entire
territorial integrity of ukraine and do
not recognize uh any
uh attempts
to
uh to uh
independently uh recognize or or
autonomize
the
separate occupied separatist occupied
regions of
eastern ukraine
canada stands with ukraine canada stands
with its allies against
this aggressive
russian
positioning and will
respond
strongly and firmly with our allies
in case of any territorial violation of
ukraine
understood i suppose what we're asking
for though is some sense of a threshold
what actions the russians would need to
take before canada would feel justified
indeed required to initiate a response
as our allies as americans as can canada
as european allies have been clear
any violation of ukraine's
current territorial integrity
will be seen as a violation by russia of
uh some founding principles of the u.n
and of the rule of law as
we
practice it
around the world right now
question from tva
thank you hello prime minister
you said that there was a lesson
for all in what happened this month
they want them to be over there
majority of canadians they know very
well that the way to get through it is
to continue being careful
and to know the things
improve when we trust you
but there are also people
for all different kinds of reasons
found themselves in difficult personal
situations
and how we'll get through this pandemic
and get through
this crisis of occupations and blockades
is to make sure that we continue being
there for each other
would like to get back
who don't want to see violence or
illegal occupations we're going to
continue being there for each other
try to bring canadians together and heal
as much as
we can
do you have any regrets
as to the way you manage the situation
for the last three weeks some people
have criticized you and said you didn't
want to dialogue with them
responsibly
always things that need to be reflected
on after any crisis or any measures that
are taken i think that we were very
clear at each stage
that's the way
the politics to influence
political policies
change things in a democracy
is not true
like canadians did six months ago
that's how a democracy works
and make them change their minds that's
not how democracy works if these people
uh
that of those who support you in your
immediate circle we have time for one
last question we're going to go to
jacques
toronto star
hi good morning uh prime minister you
mentioned earlier about oversight and
you talked about the parliamentary
committee i'm wondering when will that
committee be struck and what exactly
will it be able to do what exactly will
its powers be
um
part of the rules around the formation
of the emergencies act is the striking
of a joint parliamentary committee
between the house and the senate
to
report back
on the use of the emergencies act after
the emergencies act has been
had been in place to talk about how it
was used and and to report back in a
fulsome way uh the discus discussions
are ongoing with
the various parties on exactly that
issue david do you want to speak to that
uh thank you prime minister thank you
jacques it's a wide-ranging set of
powers that the committee has to go back
and look at uh
first of all the declaration uh the
justifications contained in that
declaration any orders as well as the
implementation of those orders so and as
well as forward-looking advice for what
we might want to do down down down the
road so that committee has a wide
ranging uh set of responsibilities i
would say first as well as powers thank
you
thanks a lot and uh prime minister i
wanted to ask you again this question
that you got earlier but i don't think i
heard a response is tonight's vote a
matter of confidence
like i said
um i can't imagine anyone voting against
this bill as expressing anything other
than a deep mistrust in the government's
ability to keep canadians safe at an
extraordinarily important time
but like i also said i am confident this
bill is going to pass
and that is the end of our press
conferences
thank you very much to the prime
minister ministers who could stay a few
moments longer
you